c'est l'histoire d'une fille qui en fait
elle a un complexe
depuis quelques temps elle a la chatte
qui sent l'oignon
que du coup elle a pas baisé depuis
hyper longtemps et un jour elle craque
d'y aller je vais en boîte je vais m'en
faire un peu de parfum tout ça on y va
elle arrive en boîte elle tombe sur un
gars qui lui plaît tout ça et puis elle
lui fait célibataire il fait oui oui
mais pourquoi tu pourquoi tu parles
comme ça en fait j'ai un problème j'ai
un complexe je sens rien j'ai pas
d'odorat
ça peut le faire du coup elle le ramène
chez lui puis elle a très très envie de
lui alors elle prend sa tête elle met
entre ses jambes et puis là il fait
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
tu m'avais pas dit tu avais la chatte à
l'oignon
non mais normalement normalement tu sens
rien donc non mais j'ai les yeux qui
pleurent
[Applaudissements]